[Music]
let's go out to Wheeling West Virginia
and talk to Laura hey Laura what's
up hi Dr John how are you doing great
how are you I am doing fantastic thanks
awesome what's up how can I help all
right so my question is um how do you
feel happy and secure spending money
when you are financially stable but you
grew up in um some kind of extreme
poverty and insecurity oo great question
so are you are you secure now go ahead
you are secure now yeah tell me about
tell me about where you are now we're
gonna go backwards on this deal oh okay
um so I'm in my mid-30s um married to a
wonderful guy um the kind most little
girls dream about like he's handson with
our kids and great provider stable but
also is a goofball um so you sound like
you're describing me except for the
stable part that's so good Kell's
rolling her eyes she's like no he's not
all right so you married a great guy yes
and and hold on and hold on and he
married an incredible woman oh thank you
okay and together you'll have created
what kind of
life okay so um we have two little ones
a 2-year-old one-year-old and currently
pregnant with our third um I am a
stay-at-home mom um he has a good stable
job not we're not rolling in the jail
but we've crafted a um very frugal life
for ourselves so zero debt outside of
our mortgage which will be paid off in
five or 10 years because um we got a
really good deal on the sixer upper
um and yeah that's kind of what our life
currently is looking like now okay oh I
love that you just said that I love that
you just said it like that because
people who grew up with not a lot say
that sentence at the end of every cool
thing that happens to
them yeah and not even cool things that
happened to them but cool things that
they have absolutely worked their butts
off for and cool things that happen
because they make sacrifices every
single freaking
day yeah they say abolutely for right
now until this all goes away and I'm
back living in a
tent
yeah I think that's where some of my
well I mean not the tent Park I know my
husband's you know would bend over
backwards to make sure that we're you
know provided for hey Laura hey Laura
yeah this whole thing about where you
found yourself now is not all because of
your husband you're involved too you
didn't you didn't Mar a fairy and he
like no sprinkled dust on you you've
worked your butt off haven't you I have
absolutely yeah I got myself financially
secure before we got married okay and I
want to be let's be clear about
this you said we've created a very
frugal
life I like to say you've created a life
of
freedom and people think of poverty and
wealth as um a dollar amount
poverty and wealth is about free or not
free cuz I know some very rich people
who are broke they're leveraged to their
souls in their vehicles in their homes
in their business
Investments very non-liquid and I know
some school teachers who I consider
wealthy because they don't owe anybody
anything they they're not going to ever
buy a house in Jamaica but they can kind
of do what they want in the World
they've crafted and you have done
that sure right yeah and maybe I'm just
not living in that freedom yet you're
not um because here here's why
especially for myself you've been
running your whole
life tell me about your childhood
yeah so it was interesting um which is
something people who grew up in mad
house say they don't ever say it was
terrible awful they're like was
interesting well it wasn't a house but
it was a cult so I grew up in a cult um
and my father was a drug addict um
that's not interesting Laura that's
awful say it it was a tough
childhood it was it was a tough
childhood will you say it was an awful
childhood I wouldn't say is awful
because my mom worked real real hard to
make sure that we were shielded from so
much
looking back as an adult now I can see
the stuff that she was trying to Shield
us from Laura just because your mom feel
like I had a bad childhood just because
your mom worked really
hard and is a should be in the next
Marvel movie because she's so
extraordinary doesn't mean then growing
up in a cult with a father who was
plagued by drug
abuse wasn't
awful true
that's true a Cornerstone of you finding
this piece that you're chasing that's so
elusive to you is choosing
reality yeah and both things can be
true okay that's fair is that fair yeah
absolutely because I can be a real jerk
right now and say your mom should have
moved you 7,000 miles away from
that true yes and I have worked through
some therapy and you know with some
issues I had you know relation to that
oh my gosh you're so you're so good at
the vague game but listen listen I
almost all of us our parents were both
and and I know my kids are going to have
both and parents too oh yeah mine too so
it's important to speak truth was
awful kids should not grow up in Cults
where adults
are like have have you have to be
shielded from your dad or from the other
adults in your family Circle but fair
enough was money really tight and
tough yes especially um when my dad left
and then shortly after my mom did get us
out of the cult um that was kind of all
one big Kur fuffle um and then yeah
money was definitely tight kind of to
the point of you know where G and I are
splitting a you know 50 Cent pot pie and
there's nothing else in the house so you
know we don't know where where the next
meal is coming from yeah
um but
then you know she did get more stable
she got a good job and um how old were
you when all this
happen uh 13 14 okay all
right um and then you know I hit my 20s
and didn't do college um but I did end
up getting a good you know career for my
self um that I was able to provide and
then from
there you know late chines met my
husband then we got married and um you
know started crafting what we wanted our
life to look like um kind of what has
brought this up to me that maybe I have
a financial
hangup is that this house that we're
living in um it's it's a fixer upper for
sure um um lots of potential
um but our next big project is kind of a
for me project which would be the
kitchen um because right now like
there's boards and stuff on the wall so
stuff doesn't blow in like it had been
but it's that's the kind of state it's
in um what kind of fix her uper this
sounds more like a hunting
blind no it's actually it's a 4,000
square foot Farmhouse Victor
um with with with boards on the wall so
things don't blow
in well now there was boards on the wall
cuz my husband wanted to see what was
behind the original walls to see what
kind of work and electrical needs to be
okay okay all right so I'm gonna give
you a couple I'm gonna give you a couple
of of thoughts here okay okay number
one a kitchen is a
heartbeat it's the chest cavity of the
of the
family
this is not just for
you that's like your husband saying hey
um I don't want to do something like to
um him being a a Craftsman him being a
cabinet maker and being like I feel
guilty about buying a uh screwdrivers
and drills and a saw like no dude that's
and I have no issues with spending on
that kind of stuff of course you don't
but that's his job yeah yeah and you've
taken the role you quit your career and
you've taken the role as homemaker
and this is the chest cavity of your
family this is where the
heartbeats y build a nice kitchen for
your family don't borrow money don't
don't don't chain yourself to a credit
card company to get this done and that's
the thing we have the money for it but
I'm like well what if we have another
baby and we need to get another V you
know my here this here this here this
you're never going to find peace until
that what if machine can finally be put
to bed h okay and by the way I didn't
grow up in abject poverty like you I did
grow up in money was very very scary
okay yeah and so um but not we weren't
split in a one pop pot I don't want to
compare what I went through with what
you went through um and i' I've spoken
extensively about how I grew up but Dad
had a great job he was a good policeman
mom stayed home with the kids with all
three of us um but things were were
dicey okay things were tight and so
a couple of things have you heard me
talk about the GPS
pins no okay I don't think so so you
know like if you're going somewhere has
anyone ever dropped a GPS pin in their
phones for you to get somewhere yes okay
so your body does
that to moments that may have cost you
your life or that activated your fight
or flight it rest in your nervous system
doesn't have an actual GPS pin but it's
it's an easy analogy for me okay here's
a couple things I think are happening
number one you grew up in a world where
those people redid their
kitens those people not us yeah we're
not those kind of people we're the kind
of people who fill in whatever your cult
said to
you so number one you have an identity
issue that's going against your nervous
system because the earliest wiring you
have is those people over there do X Y
or Z this is why changing political
affiliations is so hard
right because they are the bad
guys and you're we think of as it's just
purely intellectual it's not it encodes
itself in our bodies okay so number one
those people spend money on kitchens we
we do this they're evil we're
great okay so your body put Bing put a
GPS pin in those people and now you're
getting you're turning into one of those
people your body starts sounding the
alarms
the next thing is you're getting ready
to have child number three you quit your
job what a job gives us is a sense of
somewhat elusory that's somewhat false
but a real sense of I'm driving my own
train and now you're not quote unquote
making a paycheck you're relying on this
guy you
married your body put a GPS pin in
relying on men
because men will leave you men will lie
to
you men will fill in the blank and even
though he's wonderful and great and he
can fix all these things inside your
body your body knows don't hitch
everything to somebody because remember
what happened last
time that's number two number
three money could all go away it could
it could do you guys have an emergency
fund where you're your own bank
yes oh yeah how much like it worth of
months of
expenses um I'd say probably about six
to eight
months so all of your job your husband's
job would have to go
away yeah and you would have to not work
and he would have to not work for six to
eight months before you had to borrow a
penny
yeah the world would look radically
different at that
moment right oh absolutely so what I'm
telling you is you're okay like I'm
talking about like ash would be falling
from the sky and like the zombies would
be coming that's that's right that's
right because even if everything if your
husband's job went away tomorrow he
would be at McDonald's you would be at
McDonald's your neighbor would be
watching your kids and Y would be able
to stretch this thing out for at least a
year yeah yes
absolutely but I want you to remember
this this is not about data or facts
this is about your nervous system trying
to keep you
safe okay so and that's why I feel so
visceral yeah it very much does to this
day money terrifies me terrifies me it
sets off a reaction in my
body
okay yep and my shows doove PR well
we're okay we're doing great okay um
yeah and even when I went to the auto
dealership a year ago to buy a car I
went to go get one car and at the last
minute I bought a Toyota Highlander it's
an amazing car I could not spend that
money I had it in cash right here's why
I'm telling you
that you got to make
peace
does your husband love you oh
yeah does he make a good
living yes if his job went away would he
go get another job he's that kind of man
oh yeah are you a good mom I am have
y'all created a world that is completely
different from the one you grew up in
100% okay your body's always going to be
trying to solve for what it knows and
what it knows is chaos and what it knows
is
a and so every time something new comes
along like stability it's going to try
to drag you back and here's the word I
want to give you and it's bananas it's
practice it's practice okay do you have
a like a thoughts Journal I wish I had a
better name for it I'm gonna come up
with a better name for it
someday I have about 50 of them that I
started with my ADHD and then didn't
continue okay very good awesome just
like my house all right all ADHD is by
the way is a body's response to chaos
it's trying to Wrangle with it y okay so
if you're watching this on YouTube I
have one right here with some stickers
on it I have subpop which is the record
label that uh launch Nirvana among
others Yeti because I want to advertise
for a cooler company Michael Easter's 2%
CL I got I got this and I carry it with
me everywhere you know what's mostly in
it me writing down thoughts to get them
out of my body and out of my head and to
ask myself this one question is this
true we're going to run out of money all
right I'm GNA write that down is this
true now we have eight months worth in
the bank we're
good people who spend money on kitchen
remodels are greedy unbelievable they're
they're capitalist pigs they're feeling
is that true no will my family be honor
blessed and honored by the great Kitchen
yes we'd be able to honor and bless
people to let them come into our giant
home and stay we don't have a a place to
go
yes will this be a warm place for my
husband to come home to every night
yes be a place that my kids are going to
bring their kids home too yes
right that's you practicing absolutely
okay here's a third thing I want you to
keep in mind it's this idea of ratios
okay ratios is what transform my life my
friend Dave Ramsey taught me this Dave
grew up very with without a lot I grew
up without a lot and then Dave's got way
more than a lot
um and but here's what he had to
say if you have
$10,000 and you buy a$1 thousand
car that's X percentage of that money
okay yeah so you can look at somebody
that has a new F-150 and think oh my
gosh they spent $75,000 on that car un
what a unbelievable disgusting
gross well if they're
making x amount of of money then the
percentage might just be the same they
might be giving away a lot and they
might be filling the blank feeling the
blink feeling the blank right so you
grow up and you and your mom are
splitting a pot
pie that's x% of how much money you
brought home that month right yeah or
how much money you had now
um youall have more than that so when
you look at your groceries you're like I
can't believe we just spent this on
groceries just do the
ratios
let's do the ratios and as long as those
ratios don't get out of whack you're
going to be okay and here's the last
last last
thing keep your eyes open and give give
like crazy give like
crazy don't give out a guilt give
because you
know you
know you've been there you haven't been
able to breathe you know hang on the
line here Laura I'm going to send you uh
my buddy Dave Ramsey's book Total Money
Makeover
and I want you to read that book with
your husband make sure you're following
those plans and then I want you to give
that book away to somebody somebody who
struggling start that path start that
giving path
there but hey send pictures of that
kitchen that y'all build I want to see
what it looks like and see how you honor
your home how you honor your
family how you honor the heartbeat of
that of that of that family that new
family that y'all are
building